[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
y
[Música]
no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ahora
a
y
[Música]
ah
no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a
[Música]
ah
e
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchas gracias y muy buenas tardes a
todos acabáis de escuchar
castellano castellano es una composición
propia y de eso os quiero hablar un poco
antes de despedirme con el siguiente
tema de la composición y de la
creatividad dicen que cada maestrillo
tiene su librillo en mi caso mi librillo
de la composición se basa siempre en las
vivencias en las emociones y en los
estados de año
me resulta casi imposible o muy difícil
componer en una rutina de trabajo diario
mi rutina de trabajo a lo mejor uno se
establece unos horarios para decir a las
cuatro me pongo a estudiar técnica
guitarrística la técnica guitarrística
es esa parte en la que hasta el gasto
que tengo en casa se va corriendo y eso
es literal eso es verdad no voy a poner
ningún ejemplo no sea que me quede solo
aquí entonces por ejemplo dices a las 5
voy a hacer repertorio del concierto de
algún concierto que tengo que preparar
pero nunca he hecho a las 6 de la tarde
me voy a poner a componer porque yo creo
que como he dicho antes viene previo hay
que haber una vivencia una emoción algo
que te mueva por dentro que te mueve y
te hace ponerte con el instrumento y ahí
ya no hay horas ya todas las horas son
pocas
entonces en el caso de este tema
castellano yo la idea la tenía muy clara
llevaba mucho tiempo que me rondaba la
idea de buscar puntos en común entre la
música tradicional de mi tierra
el flamenco no y bueno hay muchas pero
en este tema en concreto busque la idea
rítmica y la idea melódica es un tema
que fusiona a mí la melodía principal me
recuerda quizá a una a una jota más
desarrollado
y la rítmica es una bulería
si hablamos de ritmo y ahora os voy a
pedir vuestra participación os he visto
dar palmas o sea que está está clarísimo
que lo vais a hacer fenomenal la jota
tiene un ritmo ternario igual que la
bulería pero con matices la bulería que
luego se explicaré un compás ternario en
este caso es un compás que tiene tres
tiempos y el tiempo uno es el tiempo
fuerte si yo lo hago con unas palmas
ahora mismo es muy fácil 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2
3 y es lo que les voy a pedir a todos
vosotros que sigáis voy a marcar dos
tiempos
vais a tocar un ritmo ternario y yo voy
a tocar la melodía principal de este
tema que luego desarrolle y que me
recuerda a mí a una a una melodía de
aquí de la tierra a una jota no marcó 1
2 3 1 2 3
[Música]
nada
muy bien muy bien muy bien salió
contratados
bueno entonces qué pasa qué tiene en
común esto con la bulería la bulería es
un ritmo de 12 tiempos
y en que se asemeja a la jota pues que
los seis primeros tiempos de la bulería
son ternarios también
los seis siguientes son binarios de
forma ordinaria o sea estaríamos
hablando de seis tiempos 1 2 3 1 2 3 y
los otros seis se marcarían un 21 2
puntos entonces un compás entero de
bulería sería 123 1 2 3 1 2 2 puntos 1 2
3 parece fácil
por los flamencos lo complicamos más
porque dentro de esos 12 tiempos al 11
12 le llamamos un 2
y empezamos el tiempo 1 para nosotros es
el tiempo 2 o sea el 2 la forma de
marcar la bulería es 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 12 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 no quería
esto es lo llevais de deberes para casa
porque no lo vamos a hacer aquí
entonces
en cuanto al siguiente tema que voy a
tocar hago el proceso contrario si en
castellano busque una melodía que
recordase a una jota castellana
sobre un ritmo flamenco de la bulería en
este tema busco un ritmo de la tierra
que no constituye ningún palo flamenco
para lo llamamos a cada uno de los
estilos flamencos
qué es un ritmo de 5 tiempo es que sí
que está en la música tradicional de
nuestra tierra que está
concretamente el ritmo charro de
salamanca
con una melodía o una armonía una forma
de interpretar lo que sí que tiene más
que ver con el filamento este tema se
llama entre mi tierra y tu luz para mí
tu luz sería el flamenco eso ya es la
parte poética de cada uno
un poco de cuento tenemos también
y bueno pues entre mi tierra y tu luz
sería eso un compás de cinco tiempos que
no es flamenco y una armonía o una
melodía que suena más a flamenco y con
este tema me despido
les doy las gracias por la participación
y me despido con una frase que a mí me
encanta que habréis oído muchas veces
que es de picasso que es la inspiración
existe pero tiene que encontrarte
trabajando
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
o no
[Música]
i
no
[Música]
ah
esto
[Música]
ahora
as
[Música]
canadá
pero no
[Música]
m
[Aplausos]
[Música]